Komputer kuantum ingin menyelesaikan masalah yang tidak bisa ditangani
oleh komputer klasik
seperti menemukan material yang tepat untuk memungkinkan
penangkapan karbon agar benar-benar
bisa melawan perubahan iklim, untuk menciptakan
pupuk yang lebih efisien yang bisa
tidak merusak bumi tapi tetap menjaga
rantai pasokan pangan yang kita butuhkan untuk memberi makan dunia
ada juga pertanyaan mendasar tentang bagaimana alam semesta kita
tersusun dan bagaimana materi berperilaku di tingkat atom
dan subatom yang perlu kita pahami
ini adalah batas berikutnya
mari kita lihat satu bidang yang sudah diteliti
pencarian baterai baru
baterai sudah mengubah hidup kita dengan memungkinkan kita membawa
komputer dan ponsel pintar
tapi masih banyak yang bisa dilakukan, baterai sangat penting
untuk masa depan energi bersih kita
baik untuk menggerakkan mobil listrik maupun
mendorong energi terbarukan
kita butuh kimia yang benar-benar berbeda
untuk menciptakan baterai
masa depan, komputasi kuantum
akan memungkinkan kita untuk benar-benar melihat ke dalam baterai
selama reaksi yang sangat kompleks untuk memungkinkan kita
memikirkan material baru
dan struktur baterai yang akan dibutuhkan
untuk menggerakkan generasi perangkat berikutnya
bagaimana kita sampai ke sana? dengan membangun perangkat kuantum paling canggih di dunia
dan platform pengembangan
dan membukanya untuk seluruh dunia
hanya dengan bekerja sama sekarang
kita akan bisa menyelesaikan masalah-masalah yang akan kita hadapi
bersama di masa depan.